What, you want my milkshake? Here.
“It’s 1819.
As the United States Congress prepares
to make Missouri
the 24th state in the Union,
Representative James Tallmage Jr.
delivers a speech.
He says slavery is morally wrong,
calling it an ‘abomination’
and a ‘monstrous scourge.’
He insists that ‘the extension
of the evil must now be prevented,’
and that slavery shouldn’t be allowed
in Missouri, or any new state.”
Obviously.
“Representative Tyler disagrees.
He believes it is a state’s right
to choose whether or not to allow slavery.
He doesn’t think the federal government
can prohibit slavery
in any newly added states.”
Whaaaaat?
“Senator Thomas proposes
what he sees as a compromise:
Missouri will join the union along
with another state, Maine.
Slavery will be allowed in Missouri
and prohibited in Maine.
He also suggests drawing a line
through territories yet to become states:
slavery will be prohibited north
of the line, and allowed south of it.”
And this is where I have
to draw the line.
That’s better.
Now, senators, congressmen,
this Missouri compromise you are proposing
is fundamentally flawed—
flawed is putting it mildly.
The compromise is based
on the middle ground fallacy.
By saying that half of the new territories
should allow slavery
while half prohibit it,
you position the two viewpoints,
pro-slavery and anti-slavery,
as equally valid.
But if one view is wrong,
while the other is right,
a compromise between them is still wrong.
And one side is definitely wrong here:
the pro-slavery side.
The whole reason this government exists,
the whole reason states exist at all,
is to serve the people.
That should include all people.
Now, I know there are those
among you who would argue otherwise,
even among those in favor
of ending slavery.
In response to your many contorted
arguments, all of them wrong,
I offer this reminder:
the idea that slavery
is morally indefensible is not new to you.
The founders of your country knew it
and many even acknowledged it publicly,
even those of them who enslaved
other people themselves.
It’s clear that the errors and delusions
on this subject
go far beyond the middle ground fallacy,
but I call your attention
to this particular fallacy
because it can have dire consequences
in many situations.
Failure to recognize the fact
that a compromise between two positions,
one of which is morally indefensible,
is also morally indefensible,
has helped to perpetuate countless
injustices large and small.
Even well-intentioned people—
which rest assured,
I don’t mistake you for—
fall prey to this fallacy,
because you humans tend to view compromise
as a virtue unto itself.
“It’s March 1861.
Seven states have seceded from the Union
since Abraham Lincoln
was elected president.
As Lincoln takes office with four more
states threatening to leave,
he promises not to interfere with slavery
in states where it exists,
but to prohibit its expansion
into new territories and states.”
“It’s April 1861, and a Civil War
has broken out over slavery.”
Some things can't be resolved
with a compromise.